I fear of conservatism taking center
stage at another college campus the
University of Connecticut UConn banning
the public from attending conservative
commentator ben shapiro as appearance
last night and offering counseling to
any students who might be offended by
what he would please todd pirate was
there and he joins us now Todd what was
it like good morning it was great yeah
he's so insightful and he's so
articulate a packed house for Ben
Shapiro at the University of Connecticut
the College Democrats also hosting his
speakers simultaneously we visited both
check it out here to see venture pair of
awesome on see I just think he's a
pretty intellectual person he has some
insightful opinions I'm here to listen
to his ignorance and I'm here to listen
to him and hopefully get my get awarded
I love the way that he you know really
comes forward with thought-out ideas we
should be able to really be open about
who we are whether we're a Democrat or
Republican
something has to be done about a system
where a few crazed leftists decide they
don't want to hear somebody speak and
therefore people from the outside who
pay taxes to universities like this one
can't get in that has to stop why is an
event like this so important for First
Amendment rights I mean I think it's
always important for people who are not
necessarily the prevailing political
view to be able to come on campus and
talk to students who are not used to
hearing these viewpoints particularly if
they find them discomforting and
uncomfortable the university's response
do you think it's an overreaction to
what happened here a few months ago I
[Applause]
think there's no question it's an
overreaction but you know they're the
ones who have to do the security
assessment so I'm not going to
second-guess their their security
assessment I will second-guess their
their assessment that they need to close
it off to the general public and I don't
care who comes there let the guy talk
you don't give us a free speech is more
important than people's feelings so
there shouldn't be acts of violence
because people disagree with one another
what do you think of the university
offering counseling to those who may not
be able to handle mr. Shapiro's speech I
think that if you can't handle it then
that's kind of sad um I mean most people
here I would think can handle a leftist
speaker so a packed house here at the
ben shapiro event line stretching around
the block let's go check out the counter
event also going on at the exact same
time I think this is a much better
alternative than going and giving ben
shapiro exactly what he wants which is
for people to come and scream at him and
protest him so he can go on post a
youtube video like ben shapiro destroys
like yukon liberals or something like
that from what we understand the
university is offering counseling to
those who don't agree or can't handle
mr. Shapiro's opinions what are your
thoughts on that
hey question yes anyone who feels that
they need mental health services from
university connect is entitled to those
services regardless of the reason what
do you think it says about the state of
the First Amendment that a university
has to limit participation in an event
that twenty years ago would have been
open to everybody from all sides to have
a discussion it's crazy I mean there
should be a full discussion between all
sides and have
you know be able to actually hear all
points of view especially at college
campus it's a great thing universities
have people like me and yes like the
person who's speaking opposite me on
this campus to give a variation of ideas
that's a wonderful thing thank you so
much I really appreciate it thank you
for coming out now the crowd at
Shapiro's event was capped at 500 people
many more turned away it was a
fascinating night what did they cap the
attendance at the Democrat rally yet I
didn't get the number it looked like
they were pretty good but you know you
heard the comments there about
counseling as a connecticut who was that
guy who came in he just came in and
totally mansplain that young lady who
was giving an eloquent counter to ben
shapiro which if you listen to ben
shapiro that's exactly what he wants he
wants a dialogue where views are
expressed and then everybody learns from
the views that guy just came in and shut
that poor woman down and I thought it
was horrible it was it was total
mansplaining and he said we need
counseling for everything did anyone
show up to go get counseling I don't
know the answer to that but you know it
really sort of there are people who
really do need counseling counseling is
a serious matter there are people with
very serious issues who need the best
balancing available but not for this but
in the world of counseling ben shapiro
is not a carrier right he is not the
reason people if you if you show up for
counseling because of ben shapiro i
think that you're way overdue
yes it was peaceful there weren't there
weren't any this thrown no fighting it
was good if there was a big positive
ready take away this is the first
amendment on display you have to
difference exactly that's right UConn
hats off to you yes fair and balanced
Aaron Bell